moi alpha condé président de la
république élu conforme à la
constitution
jugé devant le peuple de guinée est ce
mon honneur la secte est de faire
respecter les dispositions de la
constitution pour la troisième fois
alpha condé 82 ans prête serment devant
la cour constitutionnelle un nouveau
mandat controversée à la tête de la
guinée
en cause une constitution adoptée lors
d'un référendum critiquée en mars
permettant alpha condé de remettre son
compteur présidentielle à 0 pour pouvoir
se représenter
une candidature qui a donné lieu à des
mois de manifestations durement
réprimées et des violences qui ont fait
des dizaines de morts civils depuis
octobre 2019
[Applaudissements]
après la proclamation de la victoire
d'alpha condé au premier tour par la
cour constitutionnelle le 7 novembre
l'opposition dénonce une fraude elle a
une nouvelle fois appelé à manifester ce
mardi alors que l'investiture du
président se déroule sous le contrôle
d'un dispositif de sécurité très
importants policiers gendarmes et
militaires ont été déployés dès le début
de la matinée jusque dans la grande
banlieue de conakry pour éviter tout
débordement
alpha condé de son côté en appel à
l'unité des guinéens je crois
profondément aux vertus du dialogue et
de la concertation et j'ai acquis et
puis longtemps la commission que la
guinée se fera avec tous les guinéens
mais chacun doit rester la loire et
barry de ces propos des seat la violence
afin que notre pays demeure une société
liberté et de responsabilité
un message rempli d'espoir reste à
savoir si les guinéens seront de cet
avis